from america it
was a sensation that they usually
experience with magic of narrowness on
their runway
efe
of a joy that made me cry it was
something very nice
simon bolivar for the tenth time it is one of
the sea management techniques
wanderers kabul prison project
in the four  walls
the fact that i live is
to be once again out of
guerrilla violence and this has
made the country polarize
in colombia
bogotá
[Music]
before seeing my things
because more understanding also the
pressure costa
liniers until the colombian breaking
night  de significante wishes to be a saint
I felt to expand that objective
initially
we moved this country forward would help
in the country at this time
robert gates by salva maldonado frei
this insect pass was reported